[Applaudissements]
paname paname on arrive moi magal et
moussa cadou paname paname on arrive à
moi mes rêves et mes chansons bien moi
je tombe amoureux de toi tu t'es tombe
amoureux de nantes a fait là il ya juste
un corps ça passait rien trop me tue
mesure combien simone à 78,78 de sa race
est très grand pour moi non ça va c'est
réacteur après un ou deux lumbago mais
c'est rien mais voilà m et 100 et je
vous vois graves ont semblé new right
woman bien sûr et de joie si vous
n'étiez pas avec le corse
ah oui tout à fait comme un enfant abîmé
dans un des quartiers animés films en
commençant blanche mais dans la merci
[Musique]
c'est ni oui ni oignons ça veut dire que
si vous dites oui ou non je vais parler
avec vous pendant une minute
on veut croquer dans un oignon d'accord
c'était qui votre concurrent le plus le
plus dangereux dans ce voyage je sais
pas s'il y avait de quoi non s'est
jamais vu en tant que fait passer les
fêtes à non je sais pas il croque
l'oignon mon slim a croqué la nuit du
haut de ma tour la tête dans les étoiles
mais lendemain à l'école
[Musique]
à moins qu'ils aient fait et devoirs je
répondais attend de moi
il faisait lire chacun de mes poèmes un
jour à québec mais papa je te dirai que
je t'aime parce que ce qu'on
anniversaire l'an passé
[Applaudissements]